Sal was out he's back today he was out
before day prevalent because he has
pneumonia and the flu I was out yeah I
think I call it from that crap on Gary's
desk that we discussed
oh yes out you're the only person here
who got sick what are you talking about
you lost your voice Ronny did he was
screaming at a party Imam no you were
sick I think it sound you didn't get a
flu shot right no I did not you're a
[ __ ]
yeah he's a [ __ ] again you should go
sit at my desk alert your face on it you
idiot yeah that's the kicker Sal's never
gotten a flu shot he refuses he refused
flu shots in the past because he says he
never gets the flu and he heard the shot
can make you sick what sound that's true
very rare is richard freaking out that
you had the flu and pneumonia I mean
seriously I don't think so because I was
courteous enough not to be in and I got
a doctor's note and I don't what isn't a
doctor like your best friend this doctor
is a very very good doctor he knows his
[ __ ] did you actually go see him to get
the note on bullet guy who's a doctor be
best friends with you yeah he's pretty
pretty bright if he's a doctor but that
doesn't mean you know he was everything
for what I'm saying is like not that
bright right now okay so I'm not that
bright therefore I shouldn't have a
bright guy no you could have a bright
friend but I don't know what's in it for
him I mean intellectually what are you
guys talking about
right he went to med school so what are
you guys chat about you talk about
[ __ ] amoeba that I can't conduct
myself in a intelligence no when you
come in here you mean like I'm a
woodshed like I don't have the ability
yeah
I love Cork so you don't know it I don't
know pani first of all I was a science
major as well I know plenty about
[Music]
Suffolk Community College after two
semesters you're not a science major I
was assigned you flunked at a science
with Suffolk Community House oh god I
had a 3.8 in science Oh
don't you have to pick a science like I
didn't realize you could just do science
I guess like biology was going to become
an x-ray technologist I was amazed you
did sounds like you was a hundred
technology I like to see the transcript
me too I saw had the lowest IQ of
staffers that thought the IQ test I know
that's I'm saying but the highest of the
wack-bag
[Laughter]